all right guys bang-bang
I have heating here steaks or to do this
man thanks for having me yeah it's
always fun for sure let's start with
just your back room I know you've been
all over the world but give us kind of a
quick two minutes on your back room
we've done yeah I started building
software back in oh three oh four got
real lucky with one called crazy egg
after trying to build twelve different
products within a couple years
that one's self-funded still running
it's like over fifteen years old now my
wife actually runs it creates heat maps
for people are clicking on a page then
I'm probably most well known for
starting KISSmetrics
which was back in 2008 we started that
2008-2009 and then that one went through
a whole bunch of ups and downs I wrote a
whole blog post called my billion dollar
mistake and how I all might personally
screwed it all up of course and then I
also invested in about probably over 150
companies now through kind of the last
like I guess 15 plus years of being in
tech and then more recently I started
company called fYI that helps you find
your documents in three clicks or less
across all the different services you
use and we go beyond just a search box
so I built software I helped other
people build tech businesses for the
most part and I've invested in all kinds
of different companies some that have
turned into unicorns others that are
kind of failed and across the board not
just software so different hardware
companies
beetus d2c before it was called d2 see
stuff like that - I think one of the
things that when you look at the
companies that you've built they are
known for they all have kind of the same
type of feel right you're not out
building what would be considered kind
of consumer social applications you're
not building the next market place in
terms of you know Brewers and lifts and
air babies of the world you're very
focused on like hey I bought this piece
of software I sell it to you or I give
it to you for free or whatever the
monetization is but it helps you do a
very specific thing right and so let me
talk a little bit about like why are you
attracted to that type of model or why
have you spent so much time go to that
type
yeah that's a really good question the
the pithy dumbshit answer for lack of a
better answer is like I don't know it
just happened so you know like I think a
lot of people pretend to be smarter than
they are like try to give you a solid
answer look hindsight's 20/20 so like I
fell into it at a time when we back in
the day I started a consulting business
doing marketing in 2003 I did that with
my co-founder and brother-in-law Neil
Patel and we just didn't want to keep
doing the same type of consulting where
we get built we're charging hourly right
we're billed for our hours and our
team's hours we started building
software and neither of us are engineers
I fake it now I don't think he tries to
I don't think even wants to touch a lot
of software if you can help it I myself
just found that like the for me it's a
personal joy of being able to build
something and have people be able to use
it but use it in a way where like the
value they get is extremely clear and
you can talk to them about that value
and make the product better I think with
a consumer product the criteria and the
way you think about it is a lot
different even though the actual
software development might be very
similar at this point and then when you
talk about like other types of
businesses like e-commerce or other ones
like I feel like I gravitated towards
software the main reason is just because
I started with it got good at it and
found my spot where like I enjoy it and
the whole ecosystem around me has
developed around building software and
having more than one software company I
work on or or have or owned or whatever
in short though it's like we just fall
into what we fall into like it's like
asking you like dude why did you fall
into Bitcoin you probably have a damn
good answer right now but at the end of
the day you just lived your life you
were open to opportunities and boom
right and like I first met you when you
were starting to company right not not I
don't know you as the Bitcoin person or
the person who talks about Bitcoin and
monetary value and economic you know the
economic system in the world and stuff
like that which like I know a lot of
people know you for probably a lot of
people are listening
yeah I tend to think that things just
happen I think it's a great way to kind
of hit - to position it and then crazy
egg was self-funded you took new outside
capital for if I understand correctly
KISSmetrics same thing KISSmetrics we
raise money for so that was our first
sort of venture-backed company and then
with with crazy egg it's been
self-funded since day one and like we
continue to like self-funded and have no
plans to take outside capital we also
like tend to like not with the venture
funded stuff but like with self-funded
businesses just keep the team super
small focus on profit not worry so much
about growth rate and things like that
in the same way that you would if you
were a venture funded and had a bunch of
money to kind of pour ahead of revenue
got it in the net
since what is kind of the pros and cons
right you've kind of seen what happens
when you don't raise money and end up
being successful and then you've kind of
seen the pressures and accelerated
timelines and things are on venture
capital and I think it's kind of become
cool to talk about not raising venture
capital now but obviously we have plenty
of examples where when it model works it
really really works and so being
entrepreneurial is done both like how do
you kind of balance the two in hindsight
there's so many camps right like for
everything like there's a camp for this
like DHH over there you know who I have
a huge amount of like admiration and
respect for and at the same time
sometimes he says things I'm like you
know that's I get it I understand you at
this point you know like like they were
role models back in the day for us in a
number of ways not the self-funded side
but the software side more than anything
else I love how they write copy and
build product so that's one camp then
you have almost like an artificial camp
I would call it which is all these
investors right and you know I'll give a
few anecdotes and then he'll I will I
promise answer the question first of all
like I don't know anyone else that's
done both and that I think that changes
my perspective and I don't care if I
have authority to speak on stuff else
becomes tough I don't have authority but
gives me a little bit extra authority to
be like look I've seen both sides I'm
neutral like I'm like
got it you got to do what's right and if
you pick the wrong option you can change
later probably not the business you're
in if you raise buddy but that's even
possible we've heard of companies being
bought back and sold and all kinds of
funny stuff look at the end of the day I
think like are you driven by short-term
freedom are you driven by long-term
value creation and and depending on
those and your sort of lens on like time
and your horizon in life like whether
it's how old you are what phase you're
in or how conscious you are to this
you're gonna make a choice one way or
another so if you feel like hey I have
this ambition and I want to go really
far you might just say other people's
money is the best way to do that because
it can get me further faster if you're
saying hey I have a job and I want to
quit my job then it's likely that
raising money unless you're in the
ecosystem already isn't the best option
for you right so I think this is very
personal and what ends up happening is
people get don't think of it that way
and instead they're like I'm in the very
I'm gonna raise money and do a start-up
right so around here where I am I'm in
the Bay Area most people are not
self-funded there very few self-funded
come easier just because there's so much
of the energy like the the work-energy
is all oriented around raising money
right well if you look out there in the
rest of the world it's not the same in
most places I think there are exceptions
like New York might be exceptional they
might be an exception but I've seen so
many self-funded businesses from LA and
New York as well and not as many from
San Francisco and it's not even like you
don't hear about them they just don't
exist here I think the way I think about
it though if I were to like sort of take
a a much higher level view on it is like
we're the amount of weight that people
put on investors and their knowledge I
think is unfair and also their
consciousness we're giving a lot of
credit to other human beings that are
just stewards of capital just like an
operator just different type of capital
different type of goal and so when I
think about investors it's funny I was
on a call right before we started
talking now
and I had to hop off it to get on this
and the person I was talking to straight
up said this to me which is basically
hey and this is just ironic and very
timely but hey you know those investors
that like we talked about I'm like yeah
he's like well they don't know anything
either
and I'm like what do you mean and he's
like you know like and we were talking
about software and the things that I
build and he builds as well and he's
like you know self-service and like you
know low LTV and like ten month payback
period and you know not having a
multi-year LTV guess what I'm like what
he's like these investors are coming
around to it love like oh so they
realized that like if your markets big
enough and it's cheap enough to acquire
customers it's okay if your LTVs not as
high because your customer acquisition
cost is low you talk to any operator any
operator that has operated a staffs miss
to some level of scale couple million
bucks 50 million bucks whatever they're
gonna tell you it's CAC in LTV and like
some formula in between there and that's
it and you know a lot of us that have
focused on self-service SAS with higher
turn have had VCS come back and say that
won't work but then we show them it's
working and now after 10 years plus of
it working the investors like yeah I
will fund that will give you a 50
million dollar valuation and a two
million dollar they are are with a
10-month like LTV like wait what you
weren't do that just like two years ago
what changed well what changed is they
need more maybe more copies to fund and
there's more data that proves that it
can work I'm not saying it will work but
there's companies out there that are
massive right hundreds of millions of
dollars in revenue with a relatively
high churn but so much customer
acquisition at the top of the funnel
that happens really cheap that like the
business does work and it's viable and
it's long-term viable so that's a really
a good example of like you take an
operator first model is how I think
about it and what that means is as an
operator of a business what's the right
wait what's the right path for you how
do you start how do you go
so if you're at a tech company you're an
engineer and you feel like you're gonna
start your own company it's very likely
you're gonna go raise money right away
because the money for you is around you
there's like a half a million dollars
waiting for you between 10 20 30 people
that you've worked with before right or
their network right and they'll vouch
for you so you'll get that first check
why would you go think about self
funding if that's your scenario because
it's just so easy I'm not saying you
shouldn't I think you should
but it's that easy to start getting that
salary or whatever some level of comfort
and you know some areas are expensive
also all these things are gonna change
I'm sure we'll talk about that in a
second but yeah so one of the things I
want to talk about is what you just
described is a model for building a
business that the investors perception
of it change the model has always worked
right you've shown that but the way that
companies are built is going to change
you describing as well and so whether
that's the way we fund the companies or
the way that we acquire users the way
that teams work from kind of a
Productivity standpoint remote versus
not like how do you think about the big
trends there what's going to change and
let's maybe kind of focus on like what
do you think is almost guaranteed to
change versus the things that people are
like ah you know 1% chance it might
change what if the changes will have a
huge impact on one of the guaranteed
changes great yeah I think the one
guarantee I see is that the cost of
labor of any kind is gonna go down
that's guaranteed we're probably gonna
see that hit labor costs and people's
ability to make money go down for the
next five or ten years we see it's it's
the clickable it happens every time
[ __ ] hits the fan so to speak I don't
know how many shits have hit the fan
this time so you know hit huh buddy bore
by cub but my count is about three to
five depending on how you think about
chain reactions but I was just reading a
paper earlier today that was talking
about we don't even know the long-term
impact it is a whole study on that just
came out this morning and I'm like okay
well it you know I throw it back at you
be like what do you know because you
probably have a whole different lens
that I do but I think from a building
business operator standpoint the cost of
hiring people is gonna go down the funny
thing is the cost of marketing I think
is gonna go up and you can almost
guarantee that and that's just the cost
of every marketing channel or tactic or
approach to marketing has consistently
always gone up especially compared to
when it for when a channel first starts
and these are things I think about a lot
having seen so many different marketing
channels evolve and sort of cost more
over time and I don't just mean like
channels where like you can pay for the
traffic like Facebook ads or something
like that I even mean things like you
know how easy it was to get on Diggs
homepage back in the day and how much
harder it got over time as a bunch of us
figured it out and started monetizing
our attention we had on there you're
seeing the same with Twitter and things
like that as well where I think
Twitter's a fascinating one because the
paid side of it has never really worked
out and I don't know if it ever will but
the organic sort of social media dish
aspect of it is incredible in terms of
reach and brand building and all that
stuff so my theory is that and this is
like tried and true if you talk to any
marketer that like every channel gets
costly over time and it gets harder and
harder to keep your costs down and
because you have to learn new tricks
because what happens is as people hop on
to the channel more tactics are utilized
they get drowned out they get copied I
mean this is this is marketing right it
happens all the time the good news is
there's new channels and new effective
ways to even merge channels together to
make things work so that you can keep
costs down but that means that the
sophistication level of your sort of
marketing and your mix and all that
stuff goes up so what's not gonna change
is I think for a long time costs of
labor any kind of labor is gonna go down
there's many reasons for that one of the
main ones being people are now used to
not having to work from an office it's
just people meeting everybody there
they're used to it whether they like it
or not like it or whether their kids are
home and like you're not talking about
that they're just used to it because
they
have to do it business wouldn't work if
all of us couldn't figure this out we've
figured it out I mean in fact like I
have some really good data that shows
that like there's a massive spike in
people looking for zoom sort of zoom
like product video conferencing products
that spike has completely died and it's
back to the normal levels that it was so
it's literally like mmm and then like
came down over the last like three or
four months and so revenues of some of
the sort of newer players spiked and are
now kind of at a more steady pace
obviously they captured whatever they're
gonna capture and now there's a lot more
to do I've seen jumps in ARR of like 5x
for some of these companies not counting
zoom even just some of the smaller ones
and when you think of it like that it's
like we've gotten used to it that's my
point like the buying cycle like we've
gotten used to it you can look at
software buying cycles see what we've
gotten used to
we've got Houston that which means that
we're probably going to be able to hire
people from anywhere a lot more than we
were used to as a society as a whole I
mean I've been working remotely for 17
years I used to say I don't wish it upon
anybody
now it's upon everybody right and a lot
of this things that I do I feel like for
myself and my businesses I don't like
being dogmatic about recommending it as
what someone else should do because I
think people are different the way they
want to work that the way they want to
do things are different for example I
give one before I kind of sort of you
know stop on this one is like I am super
surprised at the amount of zoom fatigue
and complaining about it and the reason
I'm surprised about it is because you
can turn off the video you could just
turn off the video I mean I was doing
this stuff back in again I'm gonna date
myself but back in the day 17 years ago
I had hop on a Skype and hit the voice
button or whatever they had because they
didn't have video and just talk to
someone I did not lose anything I have
relationships from back then of people
I've worked with for three or four
companies I barely met them in person
some of them I've never met in person
right at my new company I'm trying to
think who have I met in person there's I
think only two people out of a 15 person
company that I
that in-person ones my co-founder and
the others are head of engineering that
I've worked with across three companies
for eight years but I haven't seen them
in like two years
are you here to have in person right but
we don't get out video calls unless like
they're with the whole team or something
it's usually like voice so anyway what I
think is happening is that there is the
way of working is completely going to
change and it changed because we got a
big shot in the arm and now we have to
do things and the implications of that
are the first one being I think because
of the other factors that are that are
kind of happening in the world labor is
gonna be cheaper and then when you add
in remote work and companies like being
super cool with it now compared to what
they were four months ago five months
ago things are gonna be cheaper to build
cheaper to make cheaper to do things
yeah and so I guess one of the things
that's interesting about this is of
course marketing gets more expensive the
cost of building goes down also there
seems to be this trend of education
where there's more and more people who
have the skills necessary to write code
market whatever we see do does that
ultimately lead to more innovation or is
it hard to predict just because we have
more people who are skilled more people
who are educated on these certain bodies
of work it doesn't necessarily actually
lead to more successful companies I like
the question I think back to your prior
if you take the prior thesis of like
look there's there was like a much
clearer way where it was one path to
build a large business which was you
raise money now there's a second way
which is don't raise any money figure it
out yourself so we the explosion of
self-funded companies is immense it's
incredible so I think there are gonna be
more successful companies in the eyes of
the operators so BC might look at a
certain company making a couple million
bucks a year and never gonna make more
money or maybe will make four in ten
years right go from two to four in ten
years but the operator if the operator
is operating with a less than five ten
person company like there and is happy
with that sort of grow
I mean they could take home a million
bucks two million bucks right in the
next ten years every freaking year it's
like than you like it's like the new
doctor's office it's like the new
dentist it's like the new sort of small
business basically is all these
self-funded software businesses in every
niche every category and this is
happening there's gonna be way more of
that are those companies innovative very
rarely almost never because they don't
have the rnd budget if you want to call
it that to go throw into innovation
prior to revenue so innovation happens
at a slower pace and over time if you
look at sort of most of the innovation
that's out there the fact that more
people are skilled you would assume that
there would be more innovation I think
there's gonna there's gonna be not as
much increase in innovation as we might
have expected because there's a lot more
sort of mimicking copycatting at best
being inspired and we see very little
sort of creativity around the solution
that you're trying to sort of build for
a customer because if you can solve it
without innovation why wouldn't you
right and in fact all this knowledge
makes you makes people think more like
that because like well we can try that
thing over there we could try that thing
over there
it's not our thing it might work in our
market it's a different market we're
gonna try the thing and and in in the
ability to see what everyone's doing is
something that people don't talk about
as much as as sort of other things so
like for example I think the thing
that's changed dramatically is like the
tooling to like see which apps are
charting in the different app stores
that's like new stuff it's five years
old like it's not ten years old and so
our ability to see what other people are
doing and imitate it has increased our
skill set that means in my opinion needs
to be a lot lower or can be a lot lower
to achieve the same amount of sort of
growth or create the same amount of sort
of value
just because the knowledge is all out
there and the ability to see what
another company's doing is like you snap
your finger you can go look at a lot of
their publicly available data and
there's a lot of it that's available
yeah and we just recently were talking
about this idea of like creators I think
are one of the groups that obviously are
starting to kind of catch this bug right
what they've realized is kind of three
things one I've got an audience right so
most companies seem to go build pricing
to find the audience these people have
done they're reversed if that audience
know product two is they actually may
not be expensive
to create a type of product well that's
a software product or literally a
t-shirt with some slogan on or whatever
and then three is they don't necessarily
aspire to build these massive
venture-backed businesses right they're
not trying to build the next kind of
billion-dollar uber you know whatever it
is they're actually pretty happy with a
million two million bucks a year right
and making maybe they can grow into
something a little bit more so maybe
talk a little bit about like what do you
see happening in that part of the world
where it's almost like this this graying
of the line between the content creators
and come to business owners
entrepreneurs yeah it's it's incredible
like I used to talk about the stuff 1012
years ago about how you wanted to build
an audience first because then you could
guarantee that you actually actually can
get at least the first shot of customers
now what we're seeing is that audience
building is much easier than ever and
and the knowledge is there and even the
ability to create something really
fantastic whether it's like a video a
meme you know what have you even like
text right like in the strategies in
fact like one of the ways we met is when
like you were really going off on
Twitter and I wanted to learn more about
it
and a mutual friend introduced us right
and we talked about it and I learned a
bunch from you about it like it's
incredible like I think that what we're
gonna see is more and more creators get
really large audiences and then they
need to figure out what to do next and
so the ecosystem of support for them I
think is what's I wouldn't say missing
but it's definitely something that we're
gonna see
we're gonna see I think a lot more
development around it so a good example
would be like a company like Gumroad
they let anyone sell something online
we're not even talking about stripe
right now right like that's I mean
Gumroad and other products are built on
top of stripe I believe and so and so
there's Gumroad there's there's things
like master class there's a youtuber
that I bumped into recently who's a
physician in the UK who was making like
$1500 or pounds whatever a
and he's making 5,000 something a week
with his YouTube videos that are like
equivalent of like tutorials and
unboxing and then he mentioned
Skillshare and it turned out he did a
video in 2019 it's 20/20 right now that
still makes a hundred plus dollars a day
for him and this is a youtuber he shared
a video about this and here's the thing
he said you're gonna love this he
basically said and like he's just good I
mean I think he's millennial ish or
whatever but he's just really good at
like hitting the objection early on in
the video so this is the objection he
had and just crack me up
he's like look I know like you know
something along the lines of like I know
it's cliche or kind of you know stupid
to share like how much money I make
right but the thing is and this was the
kicker for me I learned from people who
did this how to do what I'm doing and so
I'm gonna do this in the hopes that even
if one or two of you watch this and get
inspired I've done my job here right he
didn't say it like that but like that's
that's exactly what the message was and
I think that that kind of that drops
that drops a mic on the whole topic it's
like yeah you watch a couple YouTube
videos you can figure out how to make
money in fact I didn't know Skillshare
enable that kind of sort of ability for
people because that ends up being like
three thousand dollars a month that's a
significant amount of money for a
significant amount of people on the
planet and all you really need is some
level of I call a dedication to the
practice because you're never gonna
start out like good you might start out
at some level of like somewhere between
a three and
seven depending on your skill set or
your natural inclination for something
but then you you practice and you build
it up and that's what this person did
it's amazing and I didn't know
Skillshare was like at that level where
it could produce that kind of income for
somebody just because of one tutorial
video they did on some Photoshop thing
or something yeah and the thing to me I
think that's really interesting is like
what you're basically talking about is
they created a piece of evergreen
content right and that piece of
evergreen content continues to monetize
over and over again and I think if you
kind of pulled back into okay let's take
podcast for exam we were talking about
Rogan and Rogan basically creates two
types of content he creates evergreen
content where you could go back and
listen to an interview he did with a
certain person from five years ago and
it's just as valuable today as it is
then and this is things you know health
or morning routines or kind of all that
kind of type of stuff there's a million
people who kind of have similar type of
content and many of those things that
are very very kind of time sensitive so
coping happens all of a sudden brings a
doctor and that doctor starts to explain
here's what's happening right now moment
whatever but when you then look at okay
well how does somebody like that
monetize I think the debate and it's
almost like this false framework has
been should they sell ads or should they
have some kind of subscription product
really where I think you're kind of
thought process in mind aligns it's like
why don't they just build things to
monetize that attention and whether
that's physical products whether that's
a software product like like ultimately
you have the customer base and you're
either gonna rent out your customer base
to somebody else cuz they're gonna pay
for ads or you're gonna monetize it
yourself and you wanna testing yourself
seems like that's the most profitable
sustainable thing to do right yeah I
mean why can't it be both why is it even
like one of these things like where it's
almost like this if you go down one path
that doesn't stop you from going down
the other path and I think that's what
the deeper discussion you and I got into
which is like well there's gonna be some
inventory where ads make sense there's
gonna be other inventory where like if
you put your own ad or your own
promotion to something that you've built
you're gonna make more off of it but
there's always like the equivalent of
remnant inventory or left over there's
rarely a time when there
at that so for example like if someone
buys one of your products they bought it
if you knew they bought it why would you
pay to that product to them again right
and and there's obviously with
podcasting in certain mediums like that
level of sophistication doesn't exist
yet right but like and I don't know if
it's gonna get there but I think the
point is just like if you have an
audience and you want to build a
business well you have the audience and
even if you want to build a business go
get an audience because then the
optionality you have of what you do next
is like wider like the what the one
issue with this and this is I think
where venture capital does destroys
optionality that's probably the best
thing I would say about venture capital
for an operator it destroys your
optionality and destruction is what
happens and the reason is if you've sold
investors on a certain type of business
they bought into that type of issus
they're they're they're buying into it
right there buying equity in it and
giving you money to go do it at some
point around like the investment round
and at some stage you don't get to
change you don't get to change
everything
I mean you can but you don't really get
to you know it's not easy it's probably
not worth the drama so to speak and I
think that's where that's where a lot of
people's mindsets get get really stuck
on there's this type of business so a
podcast business and there's this way
that it's monetized but when you look at
all the sort of stories we hear about of
outliers of success they're outliers
because they just went against the norm
they what they did the thing that was
uncommon at that time and that's what
led to their massive success kylie
jenner right really a good example of
going outside the norm you can dig into
the data and dispute the facts around
like the numbers cuz like there's a lot
that's come out on that but you can't
dispute the simple fact that she had an
audience and she really got an audience
alignment with what she was selling that
that means that somebody understood the
audience somebody knew what they would
buy
and then built out built out whatever
they had to whether it's business
processes hiring or just picking the
right partners to monetize and those
kind of options even those multiple
options I said you have that option
allottee you can pick partners to do do
things today and sell to your audience
where you don't have to do all the work
either as long as you're able to get the
partners and find the right partners it
can be very successful can you think of
examples where kind of creators have
built software products that ended up
scaling I think a lot of the examples
that people normally go to or you take
the Kardashians for example where they
use physical beauty products you play
things around merchandise like it's
always seems to be physical products I
would maybe make the argument like
navall and maybe with the venture hacks
that eventually turned that into
angellist might be one example but any
others that you could think of we're
audience both first and then there's
software product yeah absolutely I got
to see this firsthand and kind of had my
little part in possibly of being a
fulcrum for this gentleman so there's a
conference called micro Kampf
it's a conference that I think is now
eight or nine years old I went to the
first five religiously in Vegas when
they were doing it not because it was in
Vegas just because that's where they did
it I don't actually gamble I like
watching people gamble though I'll put
like all my money on red or black and
flax I could call it so I don't play
poker or anything I think I think life
is the biggest gamble we have and that's
the one I like to invest in so basically
there's this conference it's for
self-funded entrepreneurs called micro
printers at the time and there's this
guy named Nathan Barry who was there and
he had this this business where he was
basically he he was a designer and a
writer is what I would call him I'm not
sure what he'd call himself at that time
but that's what I would call him because
what he would do is he would blog and he
would sell ebooks and he would teach
people how to blog and sell ebooks and
this is to a tech audience of folks who
could program for the most part like and
also our designers and in the
Sene so to speak or in tech and he
basically was building these landing
pages and sending emails and like doing
the whole thing to like sell ebooks off
of a blog right so he built the audience
off of blogging some really great stuff
he started sharing how he was doing it
and then he launched a product that I'm
sure many of the people listening know
called convertkit which is a software
product and it was built on the back of
the audience that he had built not the
software first I don't even think he
thought of the software first and then
at one point at a micro comm Tim and I
were chatting we were walking from one
place to another after kind of
after-hours possibly maybe walking over
dinner or something and he was just
asking for some thoughts for me and I
just told him like look you should just
like if you're not convicted on your
software just stop like don't do it do
the other thing because other things
making you like 100 grand or 200 grand a
year or more I don't remember but enough
that like you don't need to do the
software thing and I think that that
really was the was a big moment for him
and he's talked about it where he
decided to do convertkit because i said
it in the crude way I was like like just
stop it like if you're not gonna focus
on it it's probably not what you should
be doing instead he went and decided to
do it and now it's like a 20 million
dollar a year business or something like
that and so that's probably like the
best example I have of somebody who
started with the audience I don't
believe he even had any thought of
building software and then it evolved
and then he created a software and now
the software even has landing pages on
it that allow you to do what he did back
in the day when he shared that I was
like oh you're back you're going back to
your roots right like this is like kind
of what you know and how you started
this thing and now he's enabling other
people to do the same they also added
commerce where now you can charge so
like I'm sure that business will get
kind of 30 40 million in revenue over
time just because of the moves that he's
making and that started you know humble
beginnings as they say but as a personal
blog writing about how to make money
selling ebooks about different sort of
tech topics that people wanted to learn
about
it always cracks me up when I see
entrepreneurs thinking the path to kind
of large financial gain is oh I'm
supposed to make no money for ten years
and then like there's this big windfall
at the end if the company is successful
and really what you're highlighting is
like if somebody can make you know two
three five six million bucks a year
every year for ten years like twenty to
sixty million dollars is most is more
than most entrepreneurs end up with when
they sell their company for $100 anyways
yeah and like at some point you get so
much cash you don't it's not that you
don't know what to do with it but you
don't need it
so then you start investing in things
right like I think he's invest in a
bunch of land and a house and this and
that like you know and stuff like that
but like that's what you end up doing if
you have cash and and then it compounds
- right if you make actual investments
that are compounding I think the the
windfall of a big lump sum is sort of a
fallacy as the only target or the way
that wealth is created I think wealth is
more commonly created even historically
when it's compounded over time off of a
business that's profitable right you're
just taking taking at home or
reinvesting it or whatever again I go
back to that analogy
these are SMBs these are like
mom-and-pop businesses this is the
equivalent of a dentist office and
running one and making a decent amount
of money we're just able to do it from
the comfort of our own home so to speak
yeah I asked Twitter for a bunch of
questions and they sent a number of
ridiculous ones but then also some
thoughtful ones so let me just run
through the other thoughtful ones I kind
of just give me your thoughts on the fly
yeah we're talking about the future of
remote work how do you think cities
evolve kind of in response I think that
cities will are very good at adapting
over long periods of time they're poor
at adapting quickly very government
oriented and so that would be the first
thing I'd say so my prediction on how
cities evolved is like I think they
become what they used to be which is
hubs of Commerce and the commerce is
just going to change so when people need
to meet in person they go to the city to
go meet in person
the restaurants tend to be there and all
that now that's only if the restaurants
don't start dispersing which I don't see
them doing because you still need a
centralized populace or population so I
think cities are gonna evolve and go
back to kind of their roots so to speak
where there wasn't as much residential
and there's a lot more office space the
other other question is if we really
turn into a world in the in the far out
further out future where there's a lot
of self-driving cars you might see
cities turn into a parking lot so some
right if I were to be silly for a second
but yeah nobody knows that's my guess
you know I think they are gonna evolve
but it's gonna take a little while for
them to evolve because they they change
well but they change slowly I love that
answer what is the greatest indicator of
success for a product manager oh that's
simple it is what you're producing what
you create what you shipped creating
value that can be extracted by the
business and I say extracted very
specifically but can be delivered to the
customer at the same time so it's this
incentive alignment between the customer
and your business and that a successful
product manager is able to do both and
both is hard because you can get growth
with the customer and not create enough
value for the business or you can create
a ton of value for the business but kill
the customer right and mainly make it so
that you don't get more customers and a
product managers job is to figure that
out and the worst place a product
manager can be in is when they've built
a bunch of things and none of them are
working because then either of those
things are happening you're kind of
screwed when I was at Facebook we honest
saying deliver more value than you take
and when you kind of think about that it
was always this feeling of look
Facebook's gonna be just fine right and
it's gonna figure out the way to extract
the value but if you can actually give
to give the value to the customers and
make sense when do you know to improve
your product verse improve your
marketing when things are not going how
you want them to yeah so I think these
two things need to work in parallel so
you have product improvements and you
have value proposition let's just call a
value proposition instead of sort of
marketing because I think the value
proposition and the product kind of go
hand-in-hand so you know it usually this
is a product managers task and that's
why I try to take the marketing
piece out of it for the moment because
if you're shipping product and you're
not changing your value proposition or
understanding what it is and who it
appeals to then you're not actually
changing your product you're literally
just making improvement hoping that
something's going to change without
changing the other aspects of the
business the other aspects of the
business are kind of your doorway right
your doorway is your value proposition
that's what people know your business
for before they even come and use it and
so to me it's not about when do you
decide which one you change I think if
the most successful businesses are
constantly iterating both at the same
time the the sort of evidence I have for
this that anyone can look up is go to
archive.org which is the Wayback Machine
find the place you can put the URL
there's like two search boxes there find
the right one
type in salesforce.com go figure out
what their old homepage look like
compare it to every home page you can
find over the years and my point will be
proven which is basically that as you
ship product you change value prop if
you're in the early days and your pre
product market fit you're constantly
trying to figure that out and what's oh
well then what you realize is a product
person's job founders job whoever's
working on the product itself and
managing it needs to also think through
how do I test value propositions before
I build product and if you can do that
then your value proposition your
marketing so to speak could be ahead but
if you're at truly testing it whether
it's with ads tweets whatever you're
doing you're able to map what you build
to what people want not what they
actually not even what they want these
days I'm all about what they need not
what they want because that's the world
we're in but like if you can figure out
what they need with a value prop I think
building the product it sort of goes
hand-in-hand with that and you have to
do at the same time I don't think it's
when do you decide I think you're doing
both at the same time yeah this is one
of the things I think was the most
surprising to me when I first moved at
the Silicon Valley right was this idea
of the best companies always seem to be
a half step ahead in what they were
testing without having built it and then
once they realized there's just enough
traction or there's just enough signal
that hey this is gonna be valuable then
they would kind of scramble to build it
and kind of serve that need and to me it
was always one of these things were
I think for whatever reason you know and
obviously wrongly like Oh people just
build things I reveal it to the world
and obviously guys you kind of see that
under working so a lot of the stuff
you're like it makes a ton of sense to
maybe I don't know ask people hey do you
want this right if they say yes and like
go build it right the key word there is
momentum right if you don't do it like
that you don't build momentum you just
build product or you just build
marketing but really that the marrying
of the two and what you mentioned which
is the testing ahead of what you have
that's the only way you build momentum
that's the only way you get to new
places I want to spend a couple of
minutes talking about bit coin and
crypto because as you imagine that was
probably the most popular types of
questions just kind of what are your
general thoughts on Bitcoin crypto
blockchain space and any kind of
insights or takeaways there I find the
most fascinating thing with with Bitcoin
and crypto was early on when for lack of
a better way to say it without any
judgment because these are friends of
mine the shadiest non tech friends of
mine were into Bitcoin before anybody
else this is when it was like five bucks
and I think that where something starts
and who it starts with greatly dictates
where where and how long it takes to hit
like mass population and that's that's
it that that kind of is my sort of
Bitcoin summary which is like it's gonna
take a while for it to unravel itself so
that consumers understand it my my
opinion is that it it's money everybody
understand money as long as you
understand simple math you understand
money this is the reason it's gonna take
a long time to like spread because we're
used to money in its current form its
current form at and in the digital realm
is wire transfers anybody that's ever
done a wire transfer I'm sorry I do him
a lot
International payments and stuff like
that and like it's terrible and
unfortunately I haven't seen Bitcoin
come to a point where like I can do a
wire transfer much easier because I'm
using Bitcoin and what I mean is
interface packaging I don't mean I can't
do it I just mean I can't do it and then
there's a big stigma which is like is it
really money and so I know you know way
more about this than I do
you're way deeper and so is your
audience but to me it starts with the
fact of where did it start and how much
of that needs to be undone for the
consumer to use it average consumer
isn't trying to do shady transactions
with it period and so if that's the case
then where do how do we get to a point
where it becomes not an underground
thing and I know that might sound
ridiculous because everyone's heard of
Bitcoin but not everyone owns Bitcoin
not every and move more importantly very
few people are transacting between each
other with Bitcoin and I could be wrong
about that that's my sort of objective
view from my perspective and you might
have better data and the things I've
seen though it's become a protocol not a
currency that's why when you say a bit
coin and crypto like they're together
right so I'm pulling two things from
there and I don't think that you're
wrong on this the first being kind of
the origination in terms of adoption
right was kind of in this shady and not
even I don't think people go as far as
and so like it was all criminal it was
just as your point like kind of the [ __ ]
the people who are always in the fringe
in terms of ideas actions I'll go
further and say it started criminal
right like objectively illegal activity
is where it started I'm not saying
that's where it ended I'm not saying it
didn't go fast but I agree with you at
the same time what I saw in the earliest
days was people who could not who had
trouble exchanging money yep and so I
think I think that part of it is it's
this weird thing where like if you go
back and look at the work of
technologies most of them that ended up
being really really big actually started
there with to your point it took a long
time for
to become mainstream right like I always
go back to like who are the first people
with beepers and cell phones like drug
dealers that's totally right okay you
know what were some of the early web
sites on the internet that made a lot of
money porn and you know all that kind of
scambling yep yeah yep
even like downloading music in movies
that's illegal right and now we have
Spotify now we have Netflix absolutely
so I think that there's this weird
balance between it's almost like the big
technologies start out there and it
takes a long time so like you have an
uphill battle in the short term but over
the long term like history is proven
that that's actually like a pretty good
trajectory to take what's your point
takes a long time the second thing I
think the more important piece is like
and this is coming from somebody who you
know it's pretty bullish a lot of people
kind of come to me and ask questions I
said listen the user experience of this
stuff sucks like it is horrendous and I
was used to exams right one extreme is
like we're still sending like material
amounts of money to random strings of
letters and numbers like my heart beats
if I send too much money in one shot
right you're like uh like a living
triple check that I really typed that
incorrectly then on the other side you
have things where even when you're not
actually sending just using it storing
it accessing it all that kind of stuff
like there is a very distinct difference
between the quality of product in kind
of the non Bitcoin like consumer facing
world in technology and the Bitcoin
world and like that should change right
I think most people are generally like
oh that will improve you know over time
but I think that's actually one of the
biggest challenges right it's just your
point people have heard of Bitcoin but
how do I get it what do I do with it
is it easy to do that right can somebody
steal it from you like those are all the
things that we've all heard people say
no I just come zombie user-experience
the consumer advantage is not clear and
and the transactions aren't happening on
on the most frequent purchases that are
happening in the world that those are
the problems right like how it gets
solved yeah I'm bullish - I mean if you
even think about the the VCR and the
video cassette recorder
like what were people doing they were
recording things from the TV and in
retrospect you're thinking well that's
kind of you record it and then you watch
it with a bunch of people that's illegal
to it its own sort of form so everything
starts that way I love that point and
we'll see like we'll just see like I
feel like it's we're in the sort of
forex trading world of it still and I'm
just looking for the signs where we get
out of it I thought we were gonna get
out of it sooner especially with like
the crypto kitties and like stuff like
that because that just starts grating
digital transactions happening but that
still stayed pretty fringe right great
businesses and all that like we're
developed but like stayed pretty friend
so you know we'll have to see we'll have
to see what happens I'm long as well I'm
definitely not deep in it like you are
but the things I've seen kind of point
to the fact that like you said it's
gonna take a while for a consumer to
feel like they're using Bitcoin now the
question that that still keeps popping
in my head is are they ever gonna feel
that way because I'm guessing the way it
turns out is a lot of the movement of
money gets powered by it but the
consumer side still feels the same for
the consumer credit cards and equivalent
yeah we invested in a business out of
Chicago called zap and they got a
products drink where literally I send
you $20 and you get $20 but they're
using the Bitcoin rails to do it and I
tend to think like that's a very easy
onboarding because whether I'm using
venmo are this like I don't care what
the technology stack is I just want you
to get a twenty months yeah the the
venmo venmo something like venn both
like this would probably do the trick
the only problem is like you need one
trick for the consumer to get hooked in
and usually it's giving away money so
little expensive i IND each episode
asking the same two questions and then
you gotta ask me one to finish what the
first is what is the most important book
you've ever read there's a book that
I've read four or five times it's called
a courage to be disliked and it's a
Algerian psychology this guy Alfred
Adler came up with this not Freud not
Carl Jung
a third one and I just recommend
everybody read it especially if you've
ever been the person that likes to be
liked which i think is about 8090
percent of population I've read it is
fantastic so I plus one that second
one's more fun which is aliens believer
or non-believer
it depends why
what's your definition of an alien which
what's yours I've had the pleasure of
asking this at three hundred plus people
so I've got a warped view of alien world
so good if everything is energy then
aliens are energy too and so if aliens
are energy too then yeah aliens exist
but they're just some energy that is
foreign to us that we don't understand
and that's of everything's energy so if
you believe that like in quantum
mechanics and everything being energy
and the ability till I you know do all
these things and like to me an alien is
just a form of communication or
awareness that we are not used to and so
a lot of things are alien in that regard
and so yes if aliens do exist they're a
form of energy that would be my sort of
response and if that's what I need tell
intelligent life who's to say who's to
say what intelligence is we're defining
it so a throwback we could get very
philosophical I've thought about this
yeah good part of my life this is for
another type for the other side for sure
you over the first person to ever bring
up the fact of everything is energy
right I think it's a fantastic way to
it's a view what uh what one question
you have for me to wrap this up what's
the question you wish people would ask
you and I'd love for you to ask yourself
that and answer it that's the one I got
that's a really good question I'm gonna
cheat because somebody asked me this
just yesterday on the podcast and I
didn't realize that it was the best
question someone had asked um but but
like when you heard it you're just like
Dan that was by far the best one
yeah and Kat Cole asked me what's the
thing that I have taken away from doing
so many of these that I wish everyone
knew and yeah that was a fantastic
question and after thinking about it it
was just like we're all much more common
than we are different right and I think
that like we just have so many inputs in
our life telling us like we're different
we're different we're different we're
different and whether it's the tribalism
is divisive in the news politic costs up
like we're all energy I tweeted that the
other day I'm like we're 60% water cuz
like there's a lot of drama right now
yes that was you yeah water right like
oh my god like wow like we are much more
similar than we are different and I
think that like you just gotta see it
right people from all walks of life live
in all these different places and just
if we can keep that in the back of our
head I feel like we're not gonna solve
all the problems but like the world
would just be a little bit you know kind
of more calm and nice and that's
probably the direction we go I'm a
believer awesome man where where can
people find you and find out stuff about
that FYI yeah fYI was that use fYI calm
and then I'm at @hn sha HN sha H on
Twitter and the reason it's HN sha and
not my first name because I own heat and
calm actually is because it was the
license plate for the first car that my
dad bought in America and he named it
after me the car so his HN cha was the
license plate so anyway that's the story
just to drop a story on you I love that
I love that all right man let's thank
you so much for doing this and let's do
it again in the future
absolutely thanks for having me